digamos que se nos pide que dibujemos
todos los hizo menos estructurales que
tienen la fórmula molecular c5 h 12 la
palabra isómero significa mismas partes
y si estamos hablando del mismo número
de átomos todos nuestros isómeros
estructurales van a tener 5 carbonos y
12 hidrógenos nuestros isómeros van a
diferir en como esos átomos están
conectados unos con otros
así que difieren en cuanto a su
estructura y por eso los llamamos y son
menos estructurales también podemos
llamarlos y son menos constitucionales
así que necesitamos 5 carbonos para
nuestro primer y somero podríamos
simplemente dibujar 5 átomos de carbono
en una cadena así que aquí están mis 5
átomos de carbono en una cadena y te
invito a que veas el vídeo de
estructuras de enlace línea antes de ver
este vídeo así que vamos a dibujar esos
5 carbonos y vamos a verificar que
tenemos el número correcto de hidrógenos
el carbono en el extremo izquierdo tiene
tres hidrógenos así que aquí tenemos
nuestros tres hidrógenos el siguiente
carbono tiene dos
lo mismo que en el siguiente carbono así
que 2 para este 2 para el próximo
carbono y finalmente 3 hidrógenos para
el último carbono
así que vamos a contar todo y
asegurarnos de que tenemos la fórmula
molecular correcta tenemos 12
es 45 carbonos así que eso es 65 y
deberíamos tener 12 hidrógenos aquí hay
tres más dos eso nos da 5
+ 2 nos da 72 nos da 9 y luego tenemos 3
más para un total de 12 así que se 5 h
12 es la fórmula molecular de este
compuesto dibujemos otro y somero de
estructurada que tiene la misma fórmula
molecular así que en lugar de dibujar 5
carbonos en una cadena ahora tenemos que
dibujar 4
así que vamos a empezar dibujando 4
carbonos tenemos un total de 5 carbonos
así que tenemos que dibujar al 5a
carbono como una ramificación de nuestra
cadena principal
así que podríamos dibujar al quinto
carbono unido de esta forma a nuestra
cadena
dibujemos esos 5 carbonos
así que aquí tenemos nuestros 5 carbonos
vamos a contar nuestros hidrógenos el
carbono de la izquierda tiene 3
así que tres hidrógenos aquí
tres hidrógenos en este carbono aquí
arriba
sólo hay un hidrógeno en este carbono
dos hidrógenos en este
y finalmente tres hidrógenos en este
carbono
así que vamos a contar todos nuestros
átomos tenemos 1 2
45 carbonos eso es 65 y luego de
hidrógenos tenemos 3 aquí
+ 3 nos da 6 más uno nos da 72 nos da 9
y tres más para un total de doce así que
se 5 h 12 es la fórmula molecular para
este compuesto
estos dos dibujos representan dos
moléculas diferentes ambas moléculas
tienen la fórmula molecular 65 h 12 pero
difieren en términos de cómo se conectan
los átomos se diferencian en términos de
su estructura así que los llamamos
isómeros estructurales uno del otro
muy bien para dibujar otro y sombrero
estructural algunos estudiantes podrían
decir podríamos comenzar con cuatro
átomos de carbono en nuestra cadena de
nuevo y esta vez en lugar de unir el
quinto carbono a este carbono lo
podríamos unir a este otro carbono por
lo que un estudiante puede dibujar esta
estructura y decir muy bien este es un
isómero estructural diferente pero en
realidad estos son solo dos maneras
diferentes de representar la misma
molécula si se analiza la segunda
estructura que acabamos de dibujar las
conexiones son iguales tenemos un ch
aquí unido a un ch3 unido a un ch 3 y
unido a un ch 2 y el ch 2 está unido a
un ch 3 esa es la misma estructura que
acabamos de dibujar aquí
así que parece que se trata de una
estructura diferente es un dibujo
diferente al de aquí pero en realidad se
trata de solo dos maneras de representar
la misma molécula
así que tenemos dos y son menos
estructurales hasta ahora vamos a pensar
en uno más ya no podemos poner cuatro
carbonos en una cadena así que lo
bajaremos a tres carbonos sabemos que
tenemos un total de 5 carbonos así que
tenemos que mostrar 2 carbonos más
unidos a nuestra cadena principal y
estos tendrían que estar unidos a
nuestro carbono central así
dibujemos a todos nuestros carbonos aquí
y vamos a añadir a nuestros hidrógenos
así que este carbono tendría tres
hidrógenos
lo mismo con este carbono
también con este
y finalmente es igual para este carbono
el carbono en el centro este carbono en
el centro aquí ya cuenta con cuatro
enlaces por lo tanto no tiene ningún
hidrógeno unido a él vamos a contar todo
vamos a contar nuestros carbonos primero
1 2
45 carbonos por lo que tenemos 65
y luego tenemos tres hidrógenos más tres
eso da 6
+ 3 nos da 9 3 es 12 así que se 5 h 12
es la fórmula molecular para este
compuesto
y este es otro y somero estructural así
que es una molécula distinta a las otras
dos por lo que tenemos un total de 3 y
son menos estructurales que tienen la
fórmula molecular 65 h 12
ahora vamos a dibujar todos los isómeros
estructurales que tienen la fórmula
molecular c3 h 8
y vamos a empezar con la molécula de la
que hablamos en el vídeo de estructuras
de enlace línea esa molécula se veía así
tenemos 3 carbonos
y luego tenemos un o h
saliendo del carbono central vamos a
dibujarlo otra vez por acá para
asegurarnos de que tiene la fórmula
molecular correcta
tenemos nuestros 3 carbonos
y en el carbono del medio tenemos un h
así que un oxígeno unido a un hidrógeno
voy a colocar dos pares de electrones
libres en este oxígeno cuántos
hidrógenos tenemos que añadir al carbono
de la izquierda bueno tenemos que añadir
tres hidrógenos así que dibujemos estos
tres hidrógenos el carbono en el centro
ya tiene tres enlaces por lo que
necesita una más
así que agregamos un hidrógeno a ese
carbono y el carbono ala derecha
necesita tres hidrógenos
así que vamos a contar todo lo que
tenemos hasta ahora vamos a empezar con
nuestros carbonos tenemos 123 carbonos
así que eso es c 3 tenemos 3 hidrógenos
aquí
y tres aquí así que eso es 6 + 1
eso es 7 y no se olviden del hidrógeno
en el oxígeno 8 así que tenemos 8
hidrógenos y obviamente tenemos un
oxígeno aquí me adelante y dibuje los
pares de electrones libres en el oxígeno
así que la fórmula molecular para esta
molécula es c 3 h 8
y sin numerar a esto si dijera que éste
es el carbono 1 y este es el carbono 2 y
este es el carbono 3 esto nos ayuda para
dibujar el siguiente y somero
estructural ya que podríamos pensar que
en lugar de que este grupo
saliera del carbono 2 qué pasaría si ese
grupo h estuviera unido al carbono 1
así que vamos a dibujar nuestros tres
carbonos aquí
y ahora ponemos nuestro grupo saliendo
del carbono 1
y vamos a dibujar la estructura de
puntos de lewis y asegurarnos de que
tenemos la fórmula molecular correcta
así que tenemos 3 carbonos de nuevo en
una fila y el carbono de la izquierda
está unido al oxígeno el oxígeno está
unido a un hidrógeno voy a colocar los
pares de electrones en el oxígeno
ahora tenemos que añadir los enlaces
carbono hidrógeno así que este carbono
necesita dos hidrógenos el siguiente
carbono también necesita dos hidrógenos
y el carbono en el extremo derecho
necesitaría 3 1 2 3 hidrógenos sumemos
lo que tenemos tenemos 123 carbonos
c3 tenemos tres hidrógenos aquí más dos
son cinco más dos son siete y uno aquí
es ocho así que se 3h ocho y por
supuesto nuestro oxígeno tenemos tres h
8 y esta es la fórmula molecular
algunos estudiantes podrían pensar
ponemos un h unido al carbono 1 pero qué
ocurre si coloco 1 h en el otro lado
aquí en este carbono así que vamos a ver
lo que obtenemos así si pongo un h
saliendo de ese carbono estas dos
estructuras representan la misma
molécula no hay ninguna diferencia en
términos de como los dos están
conectados estructuralmente así que este
no es un nuevo y somero estructural solo
una forma diferente de ver esta molécula
ahora vamos a dibujar una más así que no
podemos ponerlo h en el otro carbono
ahora tenemos que pensar en algo más que
podamos hacer bueno podríamos en esta
ocasión poner dos carbonos en una cadena
y poner un oxígeno en medio dibujamos
este oxígeno aquí para romper nuestra
cadena de carbonos ahora tenemos un
carbono unido a otro carbono que está
unido a un oxígeno que a su vez está
unido a otro carbono y luego colocamos
nuestros hidrógenos hay tres hidrógenos
en este carbono
tenemos dos hidrógenos en este otro
carbono
otros tres en este carbono
y voy a dibujar dos pares de electrones
en el oxígeno de esta manera vamos a
contar lo que tenemos así que tenemos
123 carbonos eso es c 3
tenemos tres hidrógenos más dos son 5 3
son 8
así que tenemos h 8 y luego por supuesto
el oxígeno así que este es otro y
sombrero estructural una vez más algunos
estudiantes podrían decir bueno
podríamos hacer esto y este sería otro
iso mono estructural pero en realidad
esta es sólo otra manera de dibujar la
misma molécula así que no es un nuevo y
somero estructural tiene las mismas
conexiones así que tenemos un total de 3
y son menos estructurales que tienen la
fórmula molecular c3 h
y conforme avances más en química
orgánica aprenderás que los primeros
dosis o menos de qué hablamos este y
este los que tienen un h estos son
llamados alcoholes y al último y somero
estructural se les llama éter
y de eso nos ocuparemos más adelante en
otros vídeos